Hey look guys my name is trying to
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we took a look at glad if you
guys haven't seen that video check it
out up there glad was just a way for us
to load kind of the modern OpenGL
functions that we need in order to use
modern OpenGL as part of our rendering
which is gonna be very important now
today it's finally time to get I am
going in to our engines this is the
first major thing that we'll actually
see on the screen which is really cool
it's gonna be the first kind of finger
we render I guess and also the basis for
a lot of our future development because
this is going to be absolutely vital for
us to be able to debug things properly
just display information on the screen
and even you eyes and there's all of
that stuff so I'm really excited about
getting this in its gonna feel a lot
more like an engine as soon as we can
get this in there
I also we're gonna see a lot of really
critical things that we need to maybe do
in the future to make this
implementation more proper because today
what we're going to do something called
a hack now if you guys aren't familiar
with how kind of software development
works I mean I'm sure you watch through
some extent is I might even link an
article below about kind of a few
different ways of I guess how you can
write software particularly there's one
way of writing software which is the
first thing is kind of make it work the
second one is kind of make it like
correct right make it bright and then
the second last one the last step is
kind of just to make it fast okay so I'm
gonna be kind of just making it work but
you can the hack everything in because I
want to see how I'm going on the screen
that's not gold by the interstate it's
pretty simple we're gonna by any means
to get there but it's gonna hack it in
we're gonna make it work and I'm gonna
obviously make it horrible but we're
gonna make it kind of usable okay now
they're making it right step is kind of
abstracting everything properly so that
instead of using raw OpenGL function
calls which is what we're gonna do we're
gonna do today
the entire I'm glorianne Durer goes
through Hazel's renderer which means
that it tells hazel how I render a
triangle heroin ready text I want to
render this one run at that right
instead of actually relying on OpenGL
that's gonna be way later because we
don't have a renderer yeah right we need
to have around refers
we can do that but I want I'm going in
before we have a renderer so that we
actually can debug our renderer as we
write it and do all of that good stuff
it's gonna be a lot easier to do that
this way I mean the last time I get fast
I mean no it should just be fast anyway
but the point is that's kind of where
we're at right now this is gonna be a
hack but it's we're gonna get I'm going
to hazel by the end of this video so I'm
pretty excited let's pop over and start
making this happen okay so the first
thing is I have forked I'm GUI
quite a while ago and I made a pre make
file for us is the same kind of thing as
with gfw you can see there is my pre
make file it is pretty simple
as always because pre make is great
there's a few problems with indentation
as usual because of tabs and spaces
whatever but I need to fix that I think
the GLW thing has the same issue as well
and also I think it still has this
vision light it's good I like W anyway
we have this we're gonna add this as a
sub Marshall to out get repository serve
it here inside C dev hazel which is
where hazel is for me I'm just gonna do
get sub module add now I actually don't
remember the syntax I think it's it's
the the repository and in the past so
that's the thing and then the path which
will put this is hazel slash govinda
slash i'm going just like that i don't
know if i should know we weren't to any
capitalization let's just do that okay
and then once that is done we should be
able to go into hazel and open our pre
make file and i'm just gonna add i'm
going into that so just like we have
with all of our other include
directories I'm gonna make one farm GUI
which will be hazel venda I am GUI and
we actually should probably look at this
yeah that's probably all we need to be
honest and then we need just do I'm go
to H and that'll include that because
this is not inside an include directory
at all so that's fine I'm gonna go
grab this and chuck it on the end of
include directories I am doing and then
also we need to link it and of course
I've got if we actually look at the ayam
GUI pre make file you can see that of
course we've got it as a static library
like everything else okay fantastic so
now if we go back we should just be able
to oops generate our projects done
reload the solution and of course we
don't actually have I'm GUI in here
because I forgot one of the most
important parts wishes to actually
include it like at this so now generate
our projects again there we go
everything is done we now have I'm GUI
over here let's try and build it okay so
of course that's succeeded and hey
little should reference it as it does ok
fantastic everything is done so now the
biggest thing we need to do is set up to
the I'm gooey layer now to do that we're
gonna have to make a new file so let's
come into sandbox I'm sorry I don't
sandbox in to hazel and then what we've
got is at the moment we've kind of got
everything it's like hazel that's cool
but what I want to do is if I show all
files here um inside hazel I've been
testing out whether or not to do this
whether or not we want to actually put
this into a folder called debug I think
in the hazel development branch I did
actually put it into a folder called
debug because I'm go is kind of I guess
like a debug thing for now though I'm
actually going to just make it fall to
cold I'm giving for it and then make a
header file and a savory thing fall I
guess cold I'm GUI layout now the thing
is I don't really think that it is
something that's just going to be used
for debug for example I mean since hazel
is quite a it's really like an
application framework I don't even know
if we will end up kind of creating our
own UI library because that's a lot of
work and if what I'm doing you know like
why why why would we kind of voice
all of all of that time kind of trying
to do that so that's kind of my line of
thinking because again if we were making
like this was like a professional kind
of game engine I guess and we're like we
probably wouldn't want our own UI thing
but because like I feel like maybe for
now at least
unless someone really wants it you can
probably just configure I'm going pretty
well to do pretty much anything you want
because it's quite a nice it really is
quite a nice little UI library okay so
I'm going lay out pretty simple we're
gonna have a constructor and a
destructor and then we're going to
probably override a bunch of stuff that
we have inside layer so the cool thing
about this is that we already have we
really probably need in these two we
already have an event system which is
really useful because of course I'm
going to use a lot of events so that's
part of the reason why I just love doing
this let's include our PCH and include I
am GUI layout name space hazel and we're
going to just create method
implementations for on everything okay
cool so it's filling up I'm going to
just call the basic constructor here
with a name so the name that we'll use
is I am go away out so this is more or
less going to be the kind of I'm GUI
layer that comes with hazel so you can
obviously just start rendering I'm going
probably on any layer I don't know I
don't know how we'll set that up but
this is like a specific layout where
we're going to render kind of debug
things it's like our debug drawer layer
this will always be drawing kind of last
or rather on top of our 3d scene and all
that um so yes it's gonna be a specific
layer in which we probably will end up
calling I am GUI kind of code or at
least being able to draw any I'm GUI
kind of windows on this so we might even
end up adding like an online GUI draw or
whatever to like other layers I don't
know how we're gonna set that up we can
talk about that later okay so what I
actually do want to do is set an
initialization code but I think it's
going to probably rely on OpenGL so what
I'm going to do what was a few things
that I wanna do
the first thing I want to do is actually
probably end up taking on attachment on
detach because I know that obviously
when a layer is attached it will already
it definitely should already have the
renderer set up so on attached on detach
will create method implementations for
those as well did it end up creating one
more yet did much more why did that okay
so inside on attachment on beach ash
when you do a few really important
things so to know what we actually need
to do what I'm going to do is go into
hazel bender
I'm gooey and then we're gonna look at
some of the examples so there's two
examples that I want to focus on one is
kind of the OpenGL 3 implementation
which is this so we'll grab that and
we'll keep that around and then the
other thing is the GL of w1 so this one
okay so that's kind of gonna be the
basis for what we're actually going to
do today now this opengl 3 thing which
does all of this GL stuff we're
basically going to copy this completely
ok so I'm gonna put it into platform
inside platform I'm gonna make a new
item sorry a new folder called OpenGL
called
OpenGL and then what I'm gonna do is I'm
actually going to end up copying and
pasting these files just directly but
I'm probably not even going to rename
them just that we really do reinforce
the fact that they are temporary and I'm
gonna put them in here and include them
in our project now we probably will have
to change a few things but we'll kind of
see how we go so this is like our direct
implementation so I'm gooood RH I mean I
think that actually should be fine I'm
not sure why that's not it
ok so this this stuff look I mean I'm
just going to strip this out because
it's our own file we will rename this
just that we have there's no there's no
kind of confusion so I am GUI OpenGL
renderer
all this and that as well and we will
see what we do here so clearly defined
I'm that's weird
will include I am GUI H in here I'm not
sure why I'm not I don't like that it's
not happy with this anyway and then we
also have to before we include anything
else we also need to include our PCH
we'll probably have to regenerate
projects as well in a minute and this
actually should be fine I think that
might just be middle studio I know it
really can't include it huh well that's
weird because it should be an include
directory and it is inside hazel so
that's a little bit weird let's just
quickly check what the include directory
is actually our vendor I am GUI include
our well that's wrong because it's just
fandom GUI so if we go back to hazel and
grab that przemek file but it's gonna
make sure that this is not saying that
and then we'll generate our projects
again ok done reload okay cool
so um now that we've done that let's try
and build our our render again we'll see
what we get alright a few errors here
okay this I can include obviously
because we've changed this to be I'm GUI
OpenGL renderer and then it's not happy
with a bunch of other things because of
course we're not including collides so
we'll include glad
okay I said it fantastic so that's done
now back in I am GUI Leyland we're going
to be able to on attach do a bunch of
things that we need so I'm gonna include
two things into here I'm gonna include
the OpenGL renderer which is actually in
hazel platform and I think that actually
includes I'm GUI itself as well but I
probably should just include go to H as
well okay so it's not happy with this
and that's a bit weird on hey let's just
a performance platform open GL okay
great sorry on attach there's a few I'm
GUI things we have to do such as you
know credit context now this stuff
should be written by the way in here
they're all gone that's great I don't
know why they disappeared I was just
clicking on the minute was closing the
tab so that's great but if we go into
examples again and we'll look at G of W
[Music]
so we have all these callbacks that we
probably care about as well as old éand
initialization cards such as create
context which I don't even know where
that is I guess that's probably in yeah
so the other thing that I'm GUI does is
a bunch of this stuff is actually
probably in like example job Soviet and
gel three inside this main file yeah so
you can see it does create contacts and
all of this stuff now I already know
what I'm doing because I've implemented
this before
but just so you know that's kind of what
I'm referencing so there's the main file
that's inside the example you're using
this the two example files which is like
example Jeff wh1 CBP and there's also
the render of the OpenGL kind of
implementation example as well so I've
measured all three so that's kind of the
idea and based on that what it's gonna
write all this stuff so when I create
the context we're gonna use
dark colors yeah and then what we need
to do is have some flags so I'll say I'm
GUI I or equals and give a get IR we're
gonna send we're gonna set some back-end
flags this is just like pretty standard
I'm GUI setup hard so it has Mouse
trousers yes we have to add a bunch of
mouse cursors as well eventually
probably not today because like the hack
implementation and has set a mouse
position okay and then what we actually
need to do if we want keys to work is
setup a key map now I think that this is
something that is inside here so that I
don't have to write everything out where
is it
that's the OpenGL implementation I'm
looking for the jobs are you one okay
there's that came out we're gonna steal
this now this is extremely temporary and
I'm actually gonna add temporary should
eventually use hazel key codes and we
might actually take a look at hazel key
code stuff in the next video because
that's important it needs to be done as
well like an input kind of polling
system as well because right now we have
an event system but if I want to
actually ask the input hey is this key
down we can't do that right now
so we need to be able to do that okay so
Jeff ww3 of course this is also
temporary we should not be including gel
type III here but as I said this is a
hack video this stuff clip or text I
think you won't worry about from now and
then the other thing way to do is
actually once we've done that is
initialize this happen jail thing which
in it for OpenGL I think there's a
different one there yeah reppin jail 3
name I think that's one one and then the
version
that we want and the world views from
now is probably going to be shortened
all right cool
so hopefully that actually ends up
initializing with the correct yellow
cell version which is what we want and I
pretty sure that should be yet so as far
as updating goes and what we want to
actually do every frame the important
one is of course I'm doing Brenda as
well as I think so new frame and also
rendered raw data so we need to do new
frame I think we do that first followed
by an GUI new frame and then we do
render and then we also we need to do
the rendered raw data and then from
there we'll actually get the draw data
for mind going okay cool that's it what
we will do is I'll just quickly write
this static called true
this was wait I want to show this demo
window with for about a shirt and a my
window so we'll show a demo window which
shall be kind of just a it's a
ninth-grader my window that has
everything we might want and then we
usually say the delta time as well so we
can get that from shelf W I think that
returns a double get time yes it does
return a double and then we'll set i or
delta time so i'm going are what is this
I'm giving our I are equals I am going
that I are
and this will be IR Delta time equals
we'll have to keep track about time so
it will say m time time - end time
otherwise we'll do 1 by 60 so just in
case our time is not set yet and then
we'll do floats and time equals 0 so the
first frame it will just do it'll just
do 1 over 60 ok cool anyway that's just
a very basically to implementation
anyway as I said we'll probably rewrite
this that's like lunchtime
ok great so that should be everything
that we need
oh we also need to set the display size
now application I think doesn't have a
window and what we need is a window I
think has a get width get height okay so
what we'll do is what we'll return this
window here so what we'll do is it's an
inline window reference get window
reporter turn window just like that
and then over here we will because the
primary thing that we want to set is the
link will display size which just tells
I'm going how big our display is so to
make that happen
we'll need to get our application on
there and have that at the moment I
thought we did ok so application is on a
single sentiment that's kind of an issue
so what we want to do is basically have
application I'll add s instance here
this should be private this should be
something that we have because
application this is only going to be one
application and wherever we are steps
out wherever we are in our code base we
will probably want to access the
application because it has important
information so what this will basically
do is hold a single turn to our
application books which gets set when we
construct our application and we should
only have one anyway so we could even
have set to make sure that you know that
we only have one application so we'll
just say instance needs to be null
application already exists we also have
s instance to this so that then wherever
we are in our code base such as here we
can just say application get and that
will kind of give us our application so
let's include hazel slash application
and application gets
get needs to be static okay cool
so now that we have this we can into
here just put app dock yet window dots
get with an app get window don't get
high all right cool
so there we go anything else about it so
we have to do events as well of course
but I think that should be that should
be pretty much all that we need to
actually get this running so I'm
interested to see if it'll work because
of course it's got a lot of just hacking
stuff in so if we go into our sandbox
app at the moment we only have our
example layer being pushed in but what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to into into
hazel H I'm just going to add in hazel
I'm Gillian go away oh and then in our
sandbox app I'm going to be push an
overlay which is going to be a lime GUI
layout okay so that is for some reason
not there Aleya that should be legit
oh yeah that's means that hazel I
thought we were inside the night space
okay cool
so now I'm kind of scared but let's hit
f5 and see what happens I'm just gonna
put a breakpoint maybe here because I
want to check out certain things to see
if they were set correctly okay so it's
not happy with a son we got a linking
error because we're missing I'm GUI I'll
show you guys because we're missing it
seems we're missing the constructor that
has no parameters that's a bit weird
because is that not it
GUI layout we're missing this only how
other be missing that oh well I mean we
actually forgot to explore tit so what
is it Havel API so that's kind of
important let's not forget that okay so
we have a debugger a board has been
called these are the best ones so I'm go
he's not happy if I hit retract and see
I'm going not happy because we didn't
call correct context or anything like
that
I actually think that maybe that's
because yeah when we attach lie is they
don't and then I don't actually uh you
know cold so layout Oh Natasha is what
should happen yeah and in push our way
so yes let's try that again okay it's
not happy again this time invalid
display size value okay cool so I have a
feeling let's just look at the call
stack quickly to see where this is
coming from on update get I oh okay all
right okay I think that maybe we should
have done that before so before we begin
the frame we actually need to set a size
so we'll do that like that and actually
we'll even do the timing first so we'll
need to move this down okay so there we
go this place lives have been set 1280
by 720 that's great delts time is 16
milliseconds let's see yeah oh okay okay
fantastic so we have I'm doing here we
can't move anything with my interact
with anything because we have no events
but how cool is this we have I'm going
rendering inside our window that's
pretty awesome okay so the next step
would be to set up all of the events now
I'm gonna leave this as a bit of an
exercise to you guys to see if you guys
can figure it out by yourselves we're
going to do this in the next video
because this videos already like 30
minutes but I will say this if you just
reference this in this implementation
that shelf W has you can see that what
actually happens is if we look at some
kind of you know key callback function
you can see what actually happens right
so what we call this previous call back
which is doesn't mat spawn a callback
where's that key callback yeah you can
see that
that's IO stuff since I'm GUI I or we
restfulness at certain variables so you
know when we press a key it set it sets
Keys down with the relevant key to true
right or it for modifiers it sets
directly whether or not they're pressed
right for the mouse position for example
there's a mouse button callback which
actually this gets done inside a loop I
believe yeah so IO mouse down gets set
inside the update Mouse position and
buttons so if you refer to this I'm GUI
in full shelf W file you should be able
to get everything set up really easy
really easily right so that's kind of an
exercise for you guys to see if you can
do but otherwise next week of course I
will show you guys how I do it and we'll
get I'm going fully kind of interactive
and working and we'll probably do things
like Mouse cursors as well because
there's there's quite a lot of stuff in
this file that needs to be done and I
definitely want to rush it in this video
I hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did it hit the like button huge
thank you as always to all the patrons
that make this series possible if you
guys aren't supporting me on patreon
deftly check it out there it really does
help support the series also you'll get
to see the next video right now because
it's already up and also also all of
this stuff all the some gooey stuff will
occurred has already been written in the
development branch that you will get
access to as well because I've got like
much more of hazel actually written
there so if you interested in kind of
just leaving ahead and you don't want to
wait then check out check out patron or
compost after dinner hope you guys enjoy
this video if you did please hit the
like button it's really exciting to see
actual stuff on the screen now even
though this is a bit of a hack and we'll
have to refactor a lot of it in the
future the actual layer stuff ending is
mostly okay it's the the renderer is a
really big thing that we'll need to work
on
once hazel actually does have its own
renderer anyway I'll see you guys next
time good bye
you
[Music]